ん
うっ
ハッハー
う
[音楽]
ねぇ
いっ
こんにちははじめ社長ですとても
困ったことがありますね
まあ見ればわかるんですけど頑張ったねーよ僕は頑張った余るほどん
なおの前を送ったのか自分でも劣りません自分でをわからないから食べたんでさぁああ
あああ
ああああああ
うーんだマネー
ua
tod 2
[音楽]
わーわー今江も随分も買って
全力で亡くしにかかりましたプレゼント企画もし一躍人には私家の中ではバカみたいに
9位
いろんなことを尽くしたんですけど
本当になくなりませんいやマジでやばいです結構笑えないやつですこの辺結構入れてみ
たんですけども
天井に届くぐらいの甘いをパーッと並べたんですけども全部でこれのし具合はあると
思ってください皆様
10日
うまい棒を受け取ってください
oha
もう日がない
だいたいでもはなぜ日に作られてて賞味期限がだいたい
2018年の9月までなんですよ
あと2ヶ月ちょいをと6ヵ月しかないんですよ思った時にもう僕はこうするしかないと
思いました
画面の皆さん皆さんねー梅棒を食べていただきたい
[音楽]
もうそれしかないんだうまい棒
完全無料大夫会を行います
明日完全無料ですお母さだ
甘い5位
みんなの笑顔を見たい
その一心です本当に十何本の感覚がなくても
どんだけ食ったほどかポーズいた伊良部本当にうまい棒食っても食っても食っても食っ
ても食っても食っても食っても食っても食っても減らなくていろんな人に配り実家には
送りいろんな人に食べてもらったんですけど一向に減る予定が無くこのままだと本当に
ヤバイと思ったので
イベントにさせていただきます本当に短ビビるぐらいあるんで
画面の皆さんにはぜひともうまい棒ただて大量入手していただき
はいみなさんたくさん持つ帰ってくださいねだけで詳細を発表いたします本当にうまい
棒を配布するためだけのイベントでございます僕はステージに立ってもできることが
ありませんあんようなんですけども
一応2018年の7月の16日月曜日の祝日に行いまして時間は13時から18時場所
は静岡市内でもう場所をね決めてるん
以上でっかい場所彼てるんですけどもさすがに人が来すぎるとやっぱ迷惑にな積んで
いっちゃうんですね応募という形を取らせていただきますよねテーマなんですけどただ
応募無料で全部無料ですたくさん食べてください
完全無料なんですけどめっちゃ人数の把握と op ると制限もかけたいので一応募集
という形になっていますが実質も全員プレゼントみたいなところではあります
うまい子が
なくならない限りは黒子盆前も直接渡しますたっちゃんはたしますから
応募の方法朝にありますがもう本当に人数だけ把握したいですよねぜひ来てください
どうか
うまい魚たちを助けてやってくださいでもがここでちょっと気になってるとかあるん
ですけども
すっげーたくさん渡すんで怖いですよね決まった数渡さないからこのイベントでうまい
棒が余るかもしれないして足りなくなるかも知れませんつねそればかりはちょっと本当
にどうしようもないんですごい勝つ準備するんですけども甘いはが亡くなった場合は
エアうまい棒配るになってしまうかも知れませんすみません
余った時が本当に怖いですもうどうしようかなと思ってます
人前制限とか把握するんですけどもそれを配りきれなかったときは頭するかなぁはその
場でゲリラで配っちゃっうはいというわけで100妻本すごいいっそそれで皆に配れる
んだったらまあ僕はまあよかっ
たのかなとも思いますというわけでぜひ皆さん
岩重ローン
学生
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ